Speaker 1: I continue to insist that the MAGA
cultists the Trump is, as Joe Biden called them,
are yes, they are indoctrinated cultists,
but they are dangerous as well. Here's just
a little bit of a sampling from the Pennsylvania
rally. Here are MAGA cultists chanting Trump won.
Speaker 3: This is where. It's hard to get
through. Steve, I just dropped by. Listen.
Listen. Close by. I'm trying drop by.
Speaker 1:
Yeah. Just because you say something over and
over and over and over and over and over again
for two years doesn't make it true. Here is a
guy who wants Trump back. I think what this guy
is saying is that his parents would abuse him.
Meaning this guy's parents abused this guy.
And thus Trump is similar and is good.
Speaker 3: What they say about Donald Trump.
They say that he's mean and everything.
Well, you know what? When you're growing up,
it was your father who kicked you. Your
mother kicked you in the ass to keep you on,
to stay in power. And that's what he does. I
want a leader. I don't want a lamb. That's right.
A leader. A leader, not a lamb. We know. Yeah.
Speaker 1: That's really more sad than anything
else, to be perfectly honest. Here is one guy who
just might be drunk, which is certainly no crime.
But if you think it's tough
to defend Trump while sober,
it's a lost cause when drunk, don't even try.
Speaker 3: You have who think the economy
turns ridiculous in a way. These other
people, they when they change your country,
they are changing it. They're ruining it. What
they're doing. Donald, Johnny boy, they can
straighten it out, I'll tell you that. Hmm. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So there is a gentleman expressing his
well thought out opinion. Here's a woman who is
wearing a Trump one shirt that's now a mainstay
at the rallies. I believe that this woman
says Obama and Hillary should be in jail.
Speaker 3: Oh, bummer. I want to come back
and say stop, as do you know, stop us.
Speaker 1: Do you want them
to stop the steal right away?
Speaker 3: Now we know who won, and that's a tough
one. Why don't they fight the cheating? And now
why we do that? Why? I know.
Come for Obama. How? Well I
know. Come forward about what led to the right.
Speaker 1: Why didn't the FBI come up for Obama
and Hillary? I think she's asking, which we know
the answers to that because there was nothing
to come after them for President Trump.
Speaker 3: Why they do that? You know.
Yeah, I have come back and we
never get up. Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: Yep. So that was, you know,
another one of these delusional declarations.
Here is a guy who was he's he was at the rally.
He was also in Washington, D.C. on January 6th.
And he says he was even investigated by the FBI.
Speaker 2: We're going to come back
the first Saturday of every month and give that.
They gave us that my president for four years.
You're going to say not my president. And have
these speeches every month like clockwork. What an
embarrassment that would be. So the Democrats had
the pulse of the security and let a riot happen
and let somebody get die so they could stop these
rallies so they could say, see, Trump rallies are
dangerous. People get killed. You know who gets
killed? We get killed. But also on top of that,
the FBI, when they came to my house,
they wanted to know if I was plotting
on overthrowing the government. Wow.
Now, what am I supposed to answer that?
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah, I am actually in.
Speaker 1: All right. So a very common thing.
Lots of Trump rallies have January 6th attendees.
One other clip for you. And this is more sad than
anything else. Here is a woman who says she camped
out for five days at the Trump rally to get the
best seats. I mean, this is this is sick and.
Speaker 3: We've been here. Me and Mike
Bowman's been here since Tuesday night.
Tuesday night, you guys. Tuesday night.
Today is Saturday. That's Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday. Five
days early to see President Trump
walking on site. And, you know,
we've had a wonderful time and we can't wait
to see the president and show him how much we.
Speaker 1: When they say this. I know that you
refer to former presidents still as Mr. President.
But the way in which these people just talk about
we want to see the president, it really seems they
think he's still the president supporting him.
Speaker 3: You incredible. Mike, how is the past
five nights better for you? Camping right here to
make sure that you get the front row spot? I mean,
what continues to encourage you to do very.
Speaker 1: Sick people.
Speaker 3: And put that much effort and
money into this? Donald Trump, I mean,
we need him back and I'll do anything, you
know, to help the support board. Yeah. I
hate you so much. And we've got some.
Speaker 1: All right. And you can just
an absolutely electric speaker, as you can see.
Imagine being this delusional. So we have a real
sickness in this country. And as I've said before,
I don't know how we educate ourselves out of this
stuff. I really don't. But I'm interested
in hearing your thoughts on how we do it.